hi there today we'll look at big self
supervised models are strong
semi-supervised learners by ting chen
simon Kornbluth kevin sworsky muhammad
nur Uzi and Geoffrey Hinton of Google
brain so this paper on a high level it's
also known as Sinclair v2 demonstrates
that if you want to do semi-supervised
learning that you're very well served by
starting out with self supervised
learning and then doing fine-tuning much
like NLP models do rather than the kind
of semi-supervised approach that image
image tasks had so far and they present
this same clear v2 which is an
improvement over the same clear approach
to self supervised pre training and they
demonstrate it outperforms
a lot of the baselines alright so if you
like content like this don't forget to
share it out and leave a like and tell
me what you think in the comments so
this paper um it sort of is kind of a
club together thing of different of
different things so they present this
new method like simply same clear v2
which is a modification of sim clear and
we'll go over that but they also try to
make like a and a scientific claim
namely that the that somehow bigger
models are better for this pathway of
learning and we'll try to untangle all
of these things so first of all we're in
the semi supprised learning regime right
here semi-supervised basically means
that you have a data set and you only
have labels for a part of that data set
so this could be like here at the bottom
10% or so because labels might be
expensive to get and so you only have a
few of them but you have much more data
that's unlabeled now sometimes this
problem is formulated as this here is
your data set and then this here is like
a different data set but one that's
close enough such that you can learn
from it and that's usually in
in NLP you'll have your data set is like
a sentiment classification task but you
have all of Wikipedia that is not
labeled but it's just text so you can
sort of pre train on it in this case
we'll be in a situation where will
artificially construct a small data set
so this entire thing here is going to be
the image net data set and this right
here is going to be our labelled portion
like we have labels now usually one has
labels for image net as well but we
artificially restrict ourselves to
simulate a situation where we have lots
of data and we only have a fixed budget
so we can only because to obtain labels
often times you have to ask humans right
to label images and let's say we're a
company and we've collected this big
data set but we only have like maybe 500
bucks on Amazon Mechanical Turk and we
only managed to get a very flat aset
labeled now we're in the in the regime
of semi-supervised learning ok this is
slightly different from what NLP does
and as I said in NLP usually assume you
have different data sets the large one
being the different distribution and in
this semi-supervised regime you often
assume that it is actually the same data
distribution but you only have labels
for some of them but there should be a
fair bit of overlap between the two
things so oh I've recently made a video
about open a eyes image GPT that kind of
goes into the into the same direction as
this work right here that basically says
pre training on unlabeled data like this
whole data set without the labels can be
a very good pre conditioner for
fine-tuning later and this paper says
the same thing so basically in in the
good old days what you would do is you
would devise a method that somehow takes
you know takes in a devise a method that
takes in a mini batch and in the mini
batch you
have your data samples and then some of
them would be labeled right here you'd
have Y and here it'd have a Y but most
of them would be not labeled and you'd
have like some sort of loss function
that would put special weight on the
ones that are labeled or somehow handle
these ones that are unlabeled in a way
you might be doing like a some sort of a
consistency loss such that if they are
very nearest near neighbors to these in
the feature space they should have
similar labels or things like this so
these semi-supervised methods they
basically try to solve the problem at
once but while taking data that is
labeled and not labeled this paper goes
into a different direction this paper
says first we should it's actually three
stages right here and they have a
diagram so I don't need to draw they
have a three stage approach three stages
the one on the left is unsupervised pre
training so they say let's forget about
the labels right now even like your
unlabeled data so even the data where we
have the labels let's forget about the
labels and let's just do unsupervised
pre-training now unsupervised pre
training in this kind of setting is also
known as self supervised pre training
and this first stage is done using a
contrasted loss and that's very similar
to sim clear to this contrastive loss so
what you'll do and they describe it very
very well here so what you'll do is
given a randomly sampled mini batch of
images each image is augmented twice
using random crop color distortion and
Gaussian blur creating two views of the
same example okay so you have an image
in your mini batch each image you take
and you make two versions of it and each
version you crop real random crop
somewhere so version one could be random
cropped here version cook two could be
random cropped here and then you put
some Gaussian blur on it and so on so a
little bit of us as you can see random
crop color distortion Gaussian blur so
what you want is two different versions
of the same image each of these versions
has been augmented in a different way
cropped in a different way
blurred in a different way such it's
it's two slightly different versions of
the same image and now you want to
enforce you want to put this through
your network so ultimately as you can
see on the right side here what you want
to end up is a a network and then okay
we'll forget about this right now what
you want to Train is this network right
here actually including these projection
layers we'll get to them later this is
the network that you want to Train so
you want to put you take your unlabeled
data you take an image you'd make two
versions of it and you put those through
the network right until the end right
here so you'll get Z 1 Z 2 these are the
the output of the network for the two
images and then what you want to do is
you want to take another image that's
not this image and also put it through
the network maybe also augment it first
and then you have Z 3 so now you have
the outputs of 2 things that are
supposed to come from the same image and
one thing that's supposed to come from a
different image and now your loss is
simply going to be make those two things
close together and push those two things
apart or those 3 actually so the loss
and this is this is the contrastive loss
of self supervised learning as you know
you don't need any labels right here you
simply say the things that come from the
same image should be close together and
the things that come from different
images should be far apart and this
relies heavily on these data
augmentations that you do right here
they also employ some other tricks like
the momentum encoder from moco from
momentum contrast and so on but this is
the main the main part so you can pull a
lot of strings here to get like another
percent of performance but ultimately
they won't see the similarity
of Zi and ZJ which are the outputs of
the same image to be close together and
then this down here they want to be far
apart Zi with Z K where K is all the
other images okay you can do this in a
mini-batch fashion so this is self
supervised learning and the reason why
you do this is you don't need labels and
it tends we know it tends to give very
very good representations so um pass
that so what this network here will
learn will be very good representation
with these self supervised loss with
contrastive loss for example gives such
good performance there have been papers
recently that modify the loss and so on
but it's not super well understood yet
but if you do it like this
there the network here will give you
already very very good representation
and we know this because we can take a
network like this and then simply train
a linear classifier on top of that on a
data set and achieve very very good
performance and mind you you have
trained it with unlabeled data right so
the the network has never been trained
to solve like image net classification
it has simply been trained to look at
the pictures and determine if you know
two versions of a picture come from the
same picture or from different pictures
and now if you simply train a linear
classifier on top of these
representations you're doing extremely
well already so we know these
representations they actually learn
something about these images so that's
the first part then stage 2 let's cancel
all of that stage 2 is you want to do
supervised fine tuning now you already
see that the arrow here coming out is
not this was a task agnostic big CNN the
arrow is actually coming out of those
those yellow boxes and the yellow boxes
are these projection heads so in the
original
seem clear paper what they did was they
they wanted originally they wanted to
train this network right here this is
like a ResNet 50 it's pretty standard in
these kind of self supervised approaches
and so on to train or these few label
approaches to train a standardized
network and this is like a ResNet 50 so
in the original sim clear paper they
said we want to make ResNet 50 as strong
as possible but in order to do this loss
right here we are going to attach this
projection head just to because the
dimensionality here I think is like 2048
and we want to do this inner product in
a lower dimension of like maybe 256 or
so so this these are just multi-layer
perceptrons these are just fully
connected layers that compress the
representation down to that and once
we're done with the unsupervised
returning we're going to throw those
away right and this ResNet is the thing
that we really care about now here they
claim okay it actually works better and
they have experiments to prove this or
to show this if you use one if you
actually leave one of these layers here
so in the end they I guess they converge
on three projection head layers and then
they only throw away the top two and
like they make this big deal out of the
fact where you know I can just call I
can just call this part right here now
the encoder and I don't so I don't know
exact like I don't see the giant deal
here like you've just made your network
one layer bigger and now you consider
that to be your encoder and the
projection head is now two layers and
that will be much easier than calling
the projection head three layers but we
leave one layer and we train from the
middle layers in any case they have this
layer additional layer right here
compared to the old sim clear and then
the representation of that goes into
supervised fine-tuning now this is
pretty easy this is exactly what it
sounds like so now you use only only
the dataset that has labels so the part
of the data set that has labels and you
do the fine tuning and fine tuning is
simply supervised learning you train
this network in a supervised fashion on
that small fraction of data that has
class labels and that already performs
pretty well and they show this in
experiments but then you can go a step
further and do what's known as
distillation or self-training and what's
distillation or self-training it's so
distillation is when you have a network
that you call the teacher Network and
that network has been trained to do some
classification maybe into three classes
pretty pretty well okay but now this is
very large and you want maybe a smaller
model so you just want like this tiny
model because you want to ship it on a
mobile device right but it's also
supposed to do this and you know that if
you just directly train this which is
called the student model it doesn't
perform as well as the teacher model
there is a better way if you have the
teacher model you can sort of transfer
the knowledge to the student model you
can distill the knowledge and how do you
do that you do that by so what would you
do in supervised training in supervised
training you would take an image put it
in and then put the label that comes
along with the image you put it up here
and you compare the output to the label
and that gives you the loss function
right now you do that right here if you
distill you put the image into both now
the teacher is already trained so its
output will be a distribution over
classes it won't be a single label it
will be like okay 90% class 1 10% class
2 0 % class 3 something like this and
now you take this as like a pseudo label
this entire distribution and you put it
here and you compare the output of the
student to that of the teacher and
that's your loss function so this kind
of the teacher might have learned to put
some nuance into the classification
well I'm pretty sure this is class one
but I'm not a hundred percent sure and
it can transfer that knowledge to the
student and that makes the student
better than had you just trained it from
the beginning from from with just the
labels right so this is distillation and
you can do this even what they call self
distillation here or self-training so
apparently this even helps if the
teacher is if the student model is the
same as the teacher model now why does
it help in this case and I think it is
not exactly the case in this case
because they always say their teacher
model has this extra projection layer
right and then the student model doesn't
have that even if they do self-training
but why does it help in this case I mean
it's it's kind of shocking and I'm
pretty sure it helps in any case but in
this particular case it helps because
now you're using the unlabeled data
again so you have a teacher model and
the teacher model is trained first using
unsupervised like this is the teacher
model right here using unsupervised
training then the teacher model is
further fine-tuned on the small data
right so it is now already pretty good
at the task but how can you get a
student model that's even better than
the teacher model it's by using again
this unlabeled that you have this giant
amount of data so what you'll do is you
take an image from the unlabeled data
and you ask the teacher model teacher
model what do you think about that image
right and the teacher model will give
you a prediction like let's say again
this 90 percent 10% 0% and then you take
the student model you input that image
and you compare its output to what the
teacher said so this combines the
teacher model you freeze the teacher
model right the teacher model is only
trained until here you take it from here
the student model is now able to take
basically the teacher it takes
everything that the teacher model knows
not only about this data but about all
the data so it kind of gets to ask the
teacher model what do you think about
this what do you think about this what
do you think about this and it it can
incorporate all that knowledge about all
of this unlabeled data and that's why
the student model here in the end if
it's the same size will probably end up
even better than the teacher model right
so distillation I think also is still
kind of a mystery of why you get a
better model or I mean to to make it
smaller if you make it a lot smaller
usually you don't up end up with a
better model but you end up with a
pretty good model that you couldn't have
gotten by just training the small small
model but so that's already pretty cool
but why you get a better model with when
they're the same size that's I don't
think that's well understood yet so
that's the three-stage approach so recap
first use all of the data without labels
to do unsupervised or self supervised
contrastive pre-training second use only
the data that has labels to do fine
tuning third either distill the learnt
classifier to a smaller model or distill
it to a model of the same size again
within both cases you would again use
the unlabeled all of the unlabeled data
okay and that's the three-step approach
that's same clear v2 in it's in all of
its form alright so they go into fine
tuning right here and yeah so they say
we elaborate with a three layer
projection head so that's the three
layer projection head this here is the
output of resonate 50 where Sigma is a
Rayleigh non-linearity and we ignore the
bias term for gravity power blah blah
blah so they contrast this here for fine
tuning sim clear uses this right here
which is just it's basically just a
classifier on top of the ow
foot of the ResNet 50 okay yada yada
yada yada this is fine tuning from the
input layer of the projection head to
fine tune from the first layer of the
projection head we have a new encoder
function as this which is ResNet
followed by fully connected layers and
you see they take the resonate 50 output
and they ship it through the first
projection layer and then there is a
task specific classifier now again why I
don't even see why they make like this
ginormous deal out of it especially
especially since the last layer of the
resonate 50 I'm not ok here is I'm not
entirely sure but are they taking the
low no they're probably not taking the
log it's ok but it's yeah I'm it's just
weird
like is there even a non-linearity at
the end right here or is this really
just like to matrix multiplications in a
row which I'm going to guess there's a
big chance that that's the case that the
last layer of this encoder is actually
not even followed by non-linearity and
therefore you'll just kind of make the
dimension different and I don't see why
you can't just just incorporate this
into the model and have to like say it
over and over again that this is a new
special thing right again this is
equivalent of tuning from a middle layer
of the projection head instead of the
output layer like ok you just make your
model a bit bigger yeah so the third
step is self training or knowledge
distillation and they give two variants
right here this variant as you can see
here this is this is just the
cross-entropy but instead of having
labels right here Y or you have the T
term what the teacher model thinks Y is
given X okay that's that's cross-entropy
but not with the true labels but with
the output of the teacher model and you
can even mix that so you can as you can
see right here you can mix this with an
actual supervised loss so this would be
the supervised loss whatever yeah I
guess that I was wrong that wasn't I
guess P of Y is always
in that case but they don't use this
particular kind I think except in one of
the ablations so how does this work it
works pretty well and so one of their
experiments as you see up here it works
pretty well in that if you have 1% of
the labels only 1% of imagenet labels
which they say is smaller or equal than
13 images per class so there's a
thousand classes and you only have 13
labels per class or less if you and they
differentiate if your encoder that you
train is a resonate 50 then you get and
you can see the dashed line here is a
supervised baseline you almost get to
the supervised baseline with one percent
of the labels and if you actually have a
larger ResNet then you get to the
supervised performance without without
99 percent of the labels and if you have
excuse me ten percent of the labels you
pass the supervised baseline so the
supervised baseline is on 100% of the
labels mind you and you only have ten
percent and this outperforms the
supervised baseline now of course you
could hear you could have another
graphic where you show Oh 100% what if
we you know what if we do the whole
procedure with 100 percent of the labels
so first we don't label the data we do
supervised self supervision then we
fine-tune on a hundred percent of the
data and then we do this distillation
again you would of course be even better
and I think they have this somewhere in
a table but this is already pretty
pretty impressive
and another claim they make right here
is about the model sizes so and this
figure is description this now relates
to the title they say bigger models
yield larger gains when fine-tuning with
fewer labeled examples so there there
are
three comparative statement words in one
sentence let's unpack this bigger models
yield larger gains so the bigger the
bigger the model the better the good
let's say when fine-tuning with fewer
labeled examples let's just look at the
graph it's pretty it's really clear so
here we have a number of parameters
going over so these are the different
models they look at how many parameters
they have to do this whole procedure and
here is the relative improvement in
percent over the top image net one top
accuracy so if you do this whole thing
with a hundred percent of the labels
right I'm gonna guess this here this
here is where they start out and you can
see as you grow your models you grow the
performance and this this is just by
increasing the model size right you have
the same data set you have the same
amount of labels you have the same
number of steps that you train for and
so on just by the fact that you make
your model bigger you gain in
performance okay now you can see that
these curves here are above one another
and these curves refer to getting small
less and less labels okay so if you only
have 10% of the labels your relative
gains are a larger this doesn't mean
that you perform better with 10% of the
labels than with hundred-percent of the
labels that would be that would be like
ridiculous well I guess in this day and
age nothing is ridiculous but for now
we're still performing better by having
more labels if we do the same procedure
right it's not like here so here this
baseline the supervised baseline only
does supervised training right so that's
why we can outperform it with less of
labels but here we do the same procedure
this is relative improvement right so
this right here the starting point would
be if you had 10
percent of labels and a 25 million model
parameter model and this right here for
example is if you have the same amount
of labels but a 200 million parameter
model and this is relative improvement
okay but what the graph says is that the
relative improvement is larger that the
relative improvement is higher the more
parameters you have which is the more
you go to the right and that effect in
itself is higher the fewer labels you
have which is the different graphs and
you can see that right here so if you
have fewer and fewer labels it becomes
more and more important that you have
bigger models and that's really
counterintuitive right because you would
expect that the bigger models they can
over fit much more easily to the fewer
labels but that doesn't seem the case so
this self supervision it really seems to
be sort of a counter to this notion of
overfitting and if you have larger and
larger models that's what they argue in
the paper you might be able to learn
more and more features that might be
useful for classification so if you have
a larger model you might you're gonna
learn more kinds of features and then
you're going to outperform because you
have more chance that these features are
going to be useful for classification
and I don't think they really make a
statement as to why that happens more
with the if you have less labels so
let's think about this if I have very
few labels very very few labels why does
it help me even more if I have a big
model well with the same argumentation
we could say and maybe they actually say
this already so I'm I might be copying
them involuntarily maybe with fewer and
fewer labels like let's say we have all
the labels that's probably too many
right if we can learn a task with some
accuracy we probably had too many labels
okay it's like weakly like
we can't learn a task we know we have
too few somewhere there is a border
where we have enough but that's like can
one number and everything else is too
too many technically speaking like
learning theoretically speaking so
usually we have too many labels and what
does that mean that probably means that
there are multiple ways like if we have
too many labels there are multiple
different features we can pick up tool
and there are multiple different paths
to learn our goals so if we have
imagenet and like that there's this
weird task to recognize a three and we
get lots and lots and lots of examples
of threes right we can we can decide on
a feature we can say oh I all the threes
that I see they have this bow down here
or all the threes that I see they have
this bend here and so on but if I only
have very few labels there might only be
like a single feature that is even
theoretically possible to learn from the
labels I'm given and therefore if I have
a bigger model in cell in pre-training
because the pre-training happens with
the same amount of data right if I have
a if I have a bigger model that does the
self supervised preaching is going to
learn more features and then there's a
higher chance that that one feature that
I'm that these very few labels that I am
able to learn something from is going to
be in these features so that's kind of
how I make sense of it in combination
what with what they're saying right here
okay so this was the main points they do
a lot of empirical studies showing the
effects of these sizes they've stressed
that it's important to have both deep
and wide no that works and they also do
this additional attention mechanism over
the convolution filters I don't want to
go into that particularly but they they
also do linear evaluation compared to
supervised compared to to fine tuning on
with 100% of the labels so they do a
very thorough empirical investigation
and yeah I I do appreciate that and they
kind of show the same things and here
they show the number of layers in the
projection head so as you increase the
number of layers in the projection head
and train from the optimal layer in the
middle your performance goes up as you
can see but it also this effect is
stronger when you have fewer labels
right you can see the differences here
are greater than the differences here or
even here when you have a hundred
percent of the labels so the fewer
labels the fewer the labels the more
benefit you have from the architecture
right here and here they show that it's
not always optimal to train from the
last projection layer but here the first
one so they I guess they converge on
three projection layers and you always
want to keep the first one around after
self supervised training as we mentioned
before okay they investigate different
different distillation losses and show
that it is actually important that you
do the distillation loss on labeled and
unlabeled sets you can see here if you
only do it if you only train with the
labels after fine-tuning you get poor
performance if you do the label and
distillation loss but only do it on the
data set where you have labels then you
get more performance if you do label and
distillation loss but also include your
unlabeled data you get even more
performance and then if you do that but
you don't do the label loss so before
we've seen you can mix the distillation
loss with the label loss if you have
lots of labels then you drop in
performance again and you can see right
here the drop in performance is
proportional to how many labeled
examples you haven't that's that's
natural right if you have the labels you
can actually mix that information in
with the distillation loss and that make
you better and here they drop point one
percent and here they drop less than one
percent by leaving away
the labeled but their point basically is
that it is more important to to distill
using also unlabeled data than it is to
distill including the label loss and
it's much easier to not include the
label or so they don't do it I guess
alright so I think that was it they they
compared as I said they compare like
self distillation where you distill into
an equally sized model and down
distillation where you distill into a
smaller model
maybe that's vice-versa and they do a
lot of comparison to other methods so
this is a very thorough work I feel and
yeah if you want more about the exact
experiments I invite you to look at the
paper and let's just have a final look
at the broader impact statement right
here so the broader remember the broader
impact statement is supposed to to force
you to think about how society might be
impacted at large by your work so it
says the finding described in this paper
can potentially be harnessed to improve
accuracy in any application or computer
vision where it is more expensive or
difficult to label additional data than
to train larger models such applications
are clearly beneficial to society for
example in medical applications we're
acquiring high quality labels requires
careful annotation by clinicians better
semi-supervised learning approaches can
potentially help save lives application
of computer vision to agriculture can
increase crop yields which may help to
improve availability of food however we
also recognize their approach could
become a potential component of harmful
surveillance systems more over there is
an entire industry built around human
labeling services and technology that
reduces the need for these services
could lead to short-term loss of income
for some of those currently employed or
contracted to provide labels so ask
yourself how much of that statement has
to do with the actual novelty
this paper and the answer is of course
zero right like you can replace like our
method in this thing with like machine
learning or computer vision in general
like oh really sim clear v2 specifically
can increase crop yields like that
specific invention of this paper will
lead to higher crop yields will lead to
surveillance systems so I'm yeah you
know I I think like I'm not gonna get
too too upset about least I mean this I
think it's quite funny but just again I
I've I wonder whether the people
advocating for these things are happy
with these statements because clearly
clearly this is just a template that you
copy/paste from paper to paper replacing
like a few words and if it's computer
vision you're like oh my deep fakes and
if it's NLP it's like ah fake news and
yeah I I wonder if really anything like
particularly is has I wonder whether
these people are happy now yeah I just
I wonder and if if they are I wonder
whether it's really for the reason that
they claim that oh now we have a
statement here of how it impacts society
because like I could have told you that
before I could have told you that before
I even read the title of the paper right
what they can broader impact statements
gonna be in any case rent too long
check out paper share doubt leave a like
comment if you disagree or agree yeah
bye-bye